you know leader of the Scottish national
party the first minister of Scotland
Nicholas Roger SNP
she's been on the political stage for
decades in government for 15 years in
charge for eight and today Nicholas
surgeon face down those privately
discussing her departure
but as long as I am first minister
by the way conference I intend that to
be for quite some time yet
thank you
as long as I am first Minister I will do
everything in my power to build the
better Scotland we all want to see
she announced further support for
low-income families this winter cash to
tackle climate change and a promise of
more information next week on the
economics of Independence we will show
how we can break with the low
productivity High inequality
brexit-based UK economy and use the full
powers of Independence to build an
inclusive fear well-being economy that
works for everyone but her main target
was the Tories it took the Tories
three years three long years to realize
that Boris Johnson was a disaster with
less trust it took them just three weeks
in her last three conference speeches
Nicholas surgeon has mentioned labor
just once but their growing popularity
means that has changed in the crosshairs
kierstama and his pledge to make brexit
work they are willing to Chuck Scotland
under Boris Johnson's brexit bus to get
the keys to Downing Street letting down
Scotland same old labor the first
Minister Ended as ever on Independence
with optimism
confidence and determination we can now
finish the job and we will thank you
Nicholas surgeon and her party continue
to defy political gravity even with
record em waiting time problems with
trains with ferries strikes possible
this Autumn and doubts over how she can
secure a second Independence referendum
you're never going to get an
independence vote are you Mr Brown of
course we are the people of Scotland
will have to say on Independence basic
democracy needs to be respected the
first Minister made that case today and
we need to progress still over that
referendum
[Music]
whatever Nicholas sturgeon's plans the
next step on the path to Independence is
the legal battle for another vote
that reaches the Supreme Court tomorrow
Joe Pike Sky News Aberdeen